No you know what make that visible as
[ __ ] please thank you anyone who plays
horror games with the visibility at what
it suggests is a maniac okay okay
Wow it's immediately immediately spooky
didn't the first one start with the
house looking normal it was this is a
boat oh we're on a spooky boat oh Jesus
I I got so nervous okay okay well this
is the West idea I've ever had
so I'm supposed to be going through here
trying all these tools Wow okay
guess I'll just kill myself this one
that why you gotta make it take so long
to open it though a dog wait got to do
that okay cutscene it's fine some of my
control done what's boot if I don't have
a say in what's happening I feel less
player agency I'm less cat all right I
take it back that's pretty scary that's
different that didn't look like that oh
yeah oh God
it's still very peaceful yeah you got
some bagels you got some pears that are
all very strange looking at the top and
another goddamn nuts team travelers PO
the directors request this section of
the ship has been closed off to all
passengers and crew we wish you a
pleasant and fulfilling state icarus
transatlantic why would you leave that
here if it's been closed that doesn't
make any sense
all right cool
yep what did I expect
what did I think was gonna happen when I
did that as if you're not gonna let me
touch the piano I've played video games
before you always let the player
play the piano okay let's just slowly
just whoop
okay made it I'm brave as [ __ ] oh god I
hate this how long have I been doing
this for roughly I actually can't tell
maybe 20 minutes and I already kind of
want to die so let's just turn that off
and never do that ever again i unlock it
that's bottom one up up down well this
does look a little bit spooky up what
was that what was that what made that
noise don't know alright this seems
chill let's just close that I've already
been through that door remember that
okay why did it save I don't like it
when it saves you know all right
don't know why we're going oh I missed
something up there that's my bad
oh cool yeah I love that that's just the
best yeah I love a good red light it
really is a nice boat like I don't I
don't like a long hallway silent hill PT
made me feel that way I don't like a
long hallway but I will say the boat is
nice why did you just have to
piano sounds and then nothing is what
she was going to say but then more
sounds occurred okay cool
uh-uh I'm not a fan of that oh I hate it
oh I'm so nervous
oh I wish I could make someone else play
cuz I love horror games I really do it's
my favorite video game this is survival
horror but man am i a [ __ ] expected
that cool yeah let's go towards the
flicker flickering light no good
probably don't need that also what is
powering that fan that cable doesn't go
anywhere what is this magic is this the
plot twist of this video game
you're not battery-operated you have a
[ __ ] cable and it doesn't go anywhere
okay yeah
doc why you gotta play me like that
frankly I don't think you have to this
is unnecessary oh cool I love descending
that's like one of my top 10 favorite
things to do and I want a game I love it
when I walk down stairs uh yeah good
[ __ ] good [ __ ] okay
yeah cool another flickering light oh my
god that door slightly ajar I'm so
stoked right now yeah there's a
headphones all right
No
oh okay well uh yep this is fine oh I
frankly I love it I feel great about it
I prefer it red Ettin strobing if you
ask me okay yeah no this is my
preference actually Oh is this different
yeah it is yeah no this is a different
hallway actually uh-huh Wow yeah sounds
cool okay yep Oh what if I went in here
oh no it opened oh I was hoping that
would be locked well now I have to do
both I prefer it when you only give me
one option okay sure yeah this is big
also and that's open no I'm good close
please thank you okay which you know
what we're just gonna close that well
why did the camera do that I didn't do
that
I did not do that at all
okay you know what I'm gonna go over
here first
and then I'll come back for you other
door cool cool cool cool all right
glad we reached an agreement oh okay
let's go through the only door left is
this back into the same [ __ ]
hallway it's gonna have the shitty
[ __ ] up and all oh you're a prick
you're a prick that doesn't mean I could
go into that other room but you know
what
I'm good I'm quite good hey hey
Oh at least it looks light in there that
has to mean something good right hey oh
okay okay okay okay
OOP this is fine oh I love it
wind always do that it's my kink
actually so more of that please oh [ __ ]
all right hmm
okay we're just gonna strafe around here
and I'm gonna [ __ ] have a great time
in this dream I can't wait I'm so
excited oh boy
all right yep yep yep yep yep
you took that [ __ ] cool yeah I'm all
black bottles all right great great
great we're leaving the room now right
I'm not gonna die walking out walked out
made it [ __ ] you getting out walking out
it's fine shadows pick me a bit all
right cool that's a hurdle we passed
with less trauma then I anticipated
okay it's getting a little bit darker
though innit it's a lot of ambient music
actually yeah
it's getting louder just the room I just
came out of love it love it
yep the thing with this
okay yep who's gonna say the thing with
the series hmm is that you never feel
comfortable you don't have like a
resident evil' safe room because
everything changes all the time all
right
loves a good flickering life ya know
into it
why'd you do that again why did you do
that I didn't move the okay yep
okay this is the same room
and you really just okay cool
yep that's a mosque I think it's paid
thank you for the donation James
well that wasn't spooky that time now
was it that was me that's fine just keep
going keep on going open that door all
right it's getting slightly more
cluttered but I don't mind I'm [ __ ]
brave oh no oh oh boy well this you're
gonna be great give me a good time I
love it yeah good cool yep uh-huh yeah I
agree
okay okay okay yeah okay this way you
want me to turn around don't you
I don't like it okay cool cool cool cool
this is fine I'm gonna run to this doll
yeah it's just Kingdom Hearts it's just
this is a Kingdom Hearts equal not a
horror game don't remember what that was
a man okay there was a man there thank
you
I really appreciate that achievement
does that mean I made progress uh
wonderful oh let's get out of bed okay
okay great
okay please never again